If you ask me, the level of the school festival at Hokkaido High School is high. Is
n't
it true that people think I'm being embarrassed when I'm compared to you? Yeah, I'm
worried about my weight, no, I'm worried about it.
I'm the student council president, so I'm
extremely light on the subject.  You're inviting me out of the mood.
Why don't you go scout out the school festival at Kita High School? Shiro asks you out on a date at the
Shinomiya Cafe. The
answer is, it
's fine as long as the Wada-type president doesn't do that. That's right,
that's right.  Yes, the chairman said that he was really worried, and
now I'm going to go
one step further and say that this was my chairman.The
two of us who were invited were together.In
contrast, I do
n't have to do anything like that.  Yo
ha ha ha